white has sacrificed a queen but in  exchange white has a knight a rook and  wait how many points pawns is that  that's one pawn  yeah one pawn but also this incredible  grip on the position yeah the structure  black has this damaged pawn structure so  white's slides and what happened it was  the screen d5 uk7 bishop takes e5 so  actually this is what the players had to  calculate that after bishop b7 white  would be losing a piece if not for this  uh queen sacrifices bishop d6 so this  definitely  andre had foreseen and evoluted that wow  this is looking very very attractive i  mean first of all white is risk free  and uh in a practical game  very very unpleasant for black to defend  against this monster night and also an  update that yeah yasipanko has has  cleaned not queen but forced resignation  thanks to his incredible domination  of forces a brilliant queen sacrifice i  mean really stunning fun wonderful  victory for yasipanko grabbing the